foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsey
show where we help people build wealth
do work they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George Campbell join this hour by the Dr
John deloney and we're here to help you
take that right next step with your life
with your money with your mental health
with your relationships with the
boundaries with your mother-in-law all
of it right here on the Ramsey Show
let's do this thing the number to call
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five Michael joins us in Orlando
Florida to kick off this hour Michael
welcome to the show
hi thank you what's going on
Yeah so basically the question is uh
should I move in back with my parents to
go to school
in a nutshell okay what's the situation
here are you doing it to save money for
location all of that yeah definitely to
save money
um location not really because it would
be it's basically a boot camp ux UI
design
um three months if it was full time the
other option would be for me to continue
working what I'm doing which is a gig
economy uh Uber
um living out of airbnbs with my
girlfriend who works remote and doing
the boot camp part time which will take
uh twice the time but obviously I'm
going to have the emotional total of uh
you know parents yeah that was my
question what's living with your parents
like
um so actually it's better than actually
living with my parents uh we'll be
blessed enough it's not as bad as I
think so I'll be living with my
girlfriend
um in uh Puerto Rico and uh their their
grandparents have a house which is
pretty available to ask us to live there
um we did it before
um but there's the issue of my mom who's
been very very verbally abusive for most
of my life which is why I've been in
Florida not in Puerto Rico
okay I missed that a little bit so
you're thinking about either going to
Puerto Rico
to live with your girlfriend's
grandparents house or going to Puerto
Rico to live with your mom
no to live uh with my girlfriend's uh
grandparents because they passed away
and they gave the house to her
so where do your parents come into play
um well really having to have their
their funding as well I would have to
work for my dad after the boot camp
every day
um and um yeah just having to face them
on a daily basis or almost a daily basis
okay but let's back that thing up so you
started the call by asking should you
live with your parents to go to college
now you're saying should I live with me
that's what the lady told me to say to
you as a question because uh everything
was a bit more loaded Yeah well yeah the
whole thing sounds like a mess
um is this full time this school
uh yeah it's full time if it's if I let
my dad funded uh 40 hours a week yes and
it's in person
no it's online completely remote so you
can live anywhere
uh technically yes but if my dad is
funding it um I haven't asked him but I
would assume you want me to what would
it take for you to cash flow this and do
this on your terms because it sounds
like right now there's a lot of
handcuffs and red tape and strings
attached right
um for me to do it in my terms it'll
have to do part-time so 20 hours a week
boot camp I don't believe you the time I
don't believe you here's why
I did two phds in a master's degree
working on a full-time job probably my
in my full-time job was probably 55
hours a week maybe six oh yeah yeah that
was a I didn't get there I was saying
that the boot camp is part-time but I'll
be working a full-time job
what job are you going to be doing
um I'm waiting to get the results for
Amazon delivery driver position but I
also just finished an interview for a
remote job as a customer success
specialist I'm waiting to for round two
there's two more rounds uh waiting so I
have those two things lined up kind of
so there's either a full-time option or
a part-time program and the part-time is
going to take six months and the full
time is going to take three months
uh correct do the part time do the part
time and grow up listen the chaos and
complexity that you're gonna run into
whether it's living in your girlfriend's
grandparents house and he gave it to her
but she that mess or going home to
verbally abusive parents that you're
gonna have to work to and I'm gonna have
to depend on them like dude don't I
don't know why you enter into any of
that chaos win for six months you're
gonna have the same thing and you're
gonna have six months of full-time work
experience as well to go on top of this
credential that you're going to get
correct yeah three months man 90 days
look at it as if there's no other option
other than Michael's got to figure this
out for himself he's got to figure out
how he's going to survive live work go
to school and if you do it that way
you're gonna get real Creative Real Fast
right and that's what I've been doing
for now but I just I think I've let the
voices of my parents get infiltrated and
I feel that I'm starting to doubt which
is why I'm in this call right now no
yeah they do they've been how old are
you
I'm 27. maybe they have been running
your life for long enough
yeah and they've been dragging you
around their life long enough fair right
I understand Fair let's cut let's cut
the court man let's cut the cord yeah
let's do it it might mean it takes you
twice as long to get through school it
might mean you work twice as much as you
wanted to but it also means you get to
do this your way right exactly that
gives me great peace yeah here's for
everybody listening if you were telling
me hey I'm going to Texas A M University
and my mom and dad have a fourth room in
their house at College Station and I can
help with my younger brother who's got
special needs and I'm also going to work
part-time and should I go home
absolutely so you got a great
relationship with Mom and Dad take it
for sure this is a situation where I
don't believe that you'll finish in
three months living in this toxic
nonsensical mess I don't think you'll
get done
okay I think you will be about four
inches taller and you'll be able to
bench press not as much as George but
you'll be able to bench press a little
bit more and you will uh be able to walk
into an interview with a credential six
months of full-time work experience and
a a straight back you see what I'm
saying right and and no uh resentment or
any sort of noise
yeah that's right yeah that's that's the
move I'd make man yeah thanks for the
call
man there's so much there John
underneath the surface of the question
which is hey I could save money I can
have school funded but there's so much
happening underneath that surface that
worries me and so many people out there
back themselves into a corner where they
go well it's either this or this and
they're both toxic situations but this
is my life instead of going there is
option C and that's almost never either
or almost never sometimes it actually is
and it's scary and like when you get
medical Diagnostics and stuff there's
there's either ORS right but man when it
comes to I'm 27 years old and I want to
get a credential I gotta do this or this
no you don't no you know you don't you
could work full time for one year and
pay cat there's a million different
options here right
um and if he gets a job it's an Amazon
delivery driver and he loves it maybe he
didn't even go to this program but
whatever all it to say is dude when you
feel yourself either or backed into a
corner it's always good to call and get
some wisdom and especially when you're
if you're 27 and single now's the time
you're going to look back and go
remember when I was working 50 60 hours
a week while in school that was crazy
because there's going to be a time when
you got kids and you have other
responsibilities and you're landlocked
it's going to be harder to do these
things yeah and let's he mentioned
something I I think it's important every
extra variable creates more chaos so hey
I want to move from my home in Puerto in
Florida to Puerto Rico live in my
girlfriend's grandparents house
that's three extra variables dude that
you don't need right don't don't create
chaos in an already complex situation go
for the easiest path even if it's not
the most comfortable Michael hang online
I want to send you our pal Ken Coleman's
book from paycheck to purpose to help
walk you through this entire process and
give you some hope this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsey personality George Campbell
joined by Dr John deloney this hour and
we're taking your calls about money
mental health relationships you name it
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five hey can I just say that was
fantastic I had my uh thank you I had my
volume turned down
so I didn't hear the music coming in and
also I heard you just talking and I
thought wow my friends would like to be
a professional he's losing it and then I
realized oh no he's a professional no
we're just live on the air on Radio
podcast YouTube you name it John get
with the times evidently you have to
turn the volume up all right so John I
have a I have a bone to pick with you
and it involves an article that I
received and I want to get your take on
it because Rachel Cruz and I have
covered this issue on Smart money happy
hour and it went gangbusters and it's
all about bones to pick with me it's
like I did something because I feel like
you're gonna you're gonna try to be a
hero on this one
let's do it so we did an episode called
guilt tipping how to deal with an absurd
tipping culture and it was the tip of
the iceberg because now John according
to Wall Street Journal tipping Has Come
For self-serve checkout
so you and the Machine and the machine
says money please
this is wild so prompts to leave twenty
percent of self-checkout machines at
airport stadiums cookie shops cafes
across the country are rankling
consumers already inundated by the
proliferation of tip screens how many
ten dollar words could this author fit
in here it is the Wall Street Journal
and here's the crazy part business
owners say the odd the automated cues
can significantly increase gratuities
and boost staff pay
you know what else could boost staff pay
paying them more not cheap uh bosses and
leaders
oh man and here's a quote from a senior
at American University in DC they're
cutting labor costs by doing
self-checkout so what's the point of
asking for a tip and where is it going
and tipping researchers I didn't know
that was a job uh the labor Advocates
say so-called tip creep is a way for
employers to put the onus for the
employee to pay on to Consumers rather
than raising wages themselves companies
say tips are an optional thanks for a
job well done
this is exhausting yeah um
so as you were talking I I man I went
from hemorrhoids to I think I've got
like some kind of lung disorder oh no
yeah my body's falling apart as I listen
to this dysentery there's two parts to
this George one is
I love I love what it says here it says
that the businesses are taking advantage
of an opportunity they are that's their
job that's what businesses do they take
advantage of opportunities right they
see a glitch in The Matrix and they're
like hey let's make some money fine
I think it is unethical
to
put the onus of paying your employees on
the
in addition to the the product or
service that somebody's just purchased
to put that on the the purchaser that's
insane be a grown-up and pay your
employees what they're worth if you
think they've done a job well done pay
them for it don't be like well I don't
know man the second thing is is I don't
lose a second of sleep over this crap
because I they can do whatever they want
it's on me and we have a culture that is
so sad when somebody makes them feel a
certain way they're making me feel sad
at the kiosk well then that's on you
dude if the kiosk that you have gone and
got your own water and put it on a
self-checkout and it asks you for a tip
and that makes you sad that's not the
business's fault that's your fault you
need to go to counseling and get friends
and also don't tweet about it just don't
do it and if you stop doing it it will
go away we have a culture it's so easy
if you don't tweet about it did it even
happen
I don't see that's just bad philosophy
right but I I I'm just not gonna lose a
second of sleep you're gonna love this
description a 26 year old who works in
PR New York City said the prompt in
general is a bit of emotional blackmail
oh my gosh now for sure this section
this this this segment is brought to you
by Preparation H because I have Atomic
hemorrhoids now it is not emotional
blackmail it's a business trying to get
more money from you all you have to do
uh 26 year old who works in public
relations in New York City is be an
adult hey jumping in John how do you
feel about with people when a person
turns the screen around and then they
ask for a tip is that feel more
emotional it it does it's awkward it's
awkward it doesn't make me feel like
emotional blackmail it just feels
awkward because I'm not giving you 38
tip right now if it's like my barber or
something that's fine but I yes if I
have to look at some 17 year old and
have this exchange like I'm sorry that
your boss doesn't pay you very well and
they're trying to guilt me into giving
you more or just to make automate me
giving you more fine but I don't feel
guilty about it it's not emotional
blackmail is it awkward yeah it can be
awkward but I'm gonna do what I think is
right in the situation and move on by
the way underground one of the biggest
disagreements my wife and I have is I
over tips I'm always over tipping what
this is doing for me is it's making me
Recon the other way correct well I don't
think that for screw
it's not generosity it's not gratuity
it's a cost right so either raise the
cost of your chicken sandwich by 25
cents or
uh and pay your employees what they're
actually Worth or
um move on yeah well I have no shame I
go to the custom tip amount and I do
0.00 enter while making direct eye
contact it's a flex jump It's a flex it
is kind of I can't stand they turn
around like I was just going to ask you
a few questions like you don't know what
the questions are exactly you know good
and well James does that make you feel
sad and uncomfortable James has always
said I'm glad you brought up the
question because it is they act like
like they don't know what questions
we don't know right
exactly that's like um calling your wife
and saying Hammond to be four hours late
getting home for our date and she'll be
like I'll have a few questions for you
when you get home and you're driving
like I wonder what they are you know
what they are you know what they are oh
thank you for that is exactly how I
thought it would go John poorly thank
you that was fun so why did you think I
was trying to be a hero because last
time we did this you're like I always
over tip which again you use that line I
do but I don't do it on demand I do it
because I want to be a person of uh like
generosity when when it becomes a demand
or when it comes like a it loses the joy
dude that's good it becomes a payment
and I'm not gonna buy a 40 chicken
sandwich we're not falling for it we're
hitting zero all right let's get to the
calls William is in Orlando William
welcome to the show
good afternoon gentlemen how you doing
what's going on
doing great um I just had a question uh
I I wanted to know is it smarter for me
to just pay off well me and my life to
pay off our student loan debt on our own
or I am a school teacher and I I do have
um or what I did hear about some Public
Service forgiveness
um as a teacher and I just kind of
wanted your expertise on that how much
do you owe
uh I owe 31 and my wife only owns those
five how much money do you guys have in
the bank
uh save at the moment probably around 10
grand and as a teacher I make around 30
35. okay so how long would it take for
you guys to take nine grand out of your
savings and then use future income to
pay this thing off how many years
yeah less than two what's this public
student loan forgiveness program gonna
take ten
uh possibly yeah it's I need to be a
teacher for 10 years for half of it to
get wiped out oh my gosh so you're gonna
wait a decade to hope that half gets
wiped out or we can guarantee our own
destiny and go this thing's gone in less
than two years and we never look back
and I can choose to work where I want to
work I can choose my own destiny without
having to worry about this thing
dangling these golden handcuffs how old
are you William
28 sir 28.
so think about 10 years ago that was
pre-biden and pre-trump
you couldn't smoke drink or vote
remember how great the world was back
there
in 10 years you know what the world's
gonna look like no idea
yes sir I'd pay these loans off and by
the way I I've been a teacher
um my wife's been a teacher
I know that it's hard when you look at
those that when you get done paying into
your union dues and you don't pay it
into your legal stuff and you're getting
a pain into your your teacher retirement
what's left is is sometimes paltry it
can be scary I get that I know that I've
lived that okay and
you put your name on a contract that you
told somebody hey if you if you help me
get through school I'll pay you back and
so for me this is just me there's an
Integrity thing did I know what I was
saying when I was 18 no did I run up six
figures yes and I did sign my name on a
piece of paper said I'll pay you back
and that that's
that's the way I've my wife and I chose
to deal with it and on top of that go
just look at the data on this thing
people who applied and people who got it
it was a half percent now it's at like a
whopping one percent because they made
it so much better those odds are
terrible yes and so I'm taking control
man if you want more on this go watch
our documentary borrowed future where we
talk about this issue we talk about what
to do and how we can overcome this
crisis but you'll be there man in no
time I had 36 Grand I paid it off in
less than two years and you can do the
same rooting for you
[Music]
thank you
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsay show and if you
haven't heard we're doing something
around here that we have never done
before right now all of the Ramsay
personalities are leading Financial
Peace University including me and I want
you to join my virtual class you can do
it from anywhere across the country join
my class it's not a competition John a
thousand percent of competition America
and Jade and Rachel are killing us
that's true that's why it's not a
competition because they're they're
smoking us there's nothing we can do
about it I I disagree I'll Never Say
Never we're Prefontaine pick one of our
classes so John is leading a financial
piece university class his starts
earlier than mine mine starts June 20th
you know when yours starts that's kind
of a flex it's the latest one mine
starts in a few weeks is yours in the
evening or during the lunch mine is
during lunch hour minus two great
if you want Financial Freedom and peace
sooner rather than later join my there's
the pitch if you want one month of just
Reckless spending before you got to shut
it down you should probably join Georgia
now that would be fun yes all right well
here's the deal you're going to learn
everything about how to handle money how
to pay off debt how to build wealth in
Financial Peace University and we're
going to be your personal cheerleaders
through the class and you're going to
have a community of thousands of others
taking the class with you and
encouraging you too and we're doing all
nine lessons in about four or five weeks
so we're gonna meet twice a week for
about five weeks and we're gonna knock
this thing out just in time for you guys
to finish out your summer have a great
fall and change the way you handle money
the turnaround on this stuff is amazing
people who go through Financial Peace
University they save thousands of
dollars they pay off thousands of
dollars and it's worth every penny you
pay for so the classes are starting to
fill up grab your spot right now at
fpu.com that's fpu.com and sign up for
either John or ice class we'll keep it
classy
see what I did there
man that's a good way to end a
conversation we're just going to keep it
classy keep it classy John because I was
trying to you know to rise above it take
the high road if you will oh that's not
one of my not one of my gifts I like to
get right in the middle of it I'm not
much of a fighter these days I don't
have it in me let's get to the calls
Andrew joins us up next in Kansas City
Andrew welcome to the show what's going
on with you
yes all right thanks for taking my call
sure
um so I I wanted to in a nutshell to ask
how does how does one
pursue an artistic career while making
uh while trying to find ways to make
passive income
oh
so there's two opposing things happening
here two opposing goals why passive
income
well currently uh the the job that I
perform right now is not what I would
call high paying and I wanted to find
ways to make passive income and my
ultimate goal you could you could say
desire would be to get into the creative
arts what does that mean when you say
creative arts
um I'm thinking either acting or writing
okay so you want to be an actor slash
writer and you need money right now
until you have that career dialed in
is that right yes because yeah it's you
know it's a subjective field and you're
only as good as other people think you
are so that's not true that's actually
not true at all you're as good as you
are talented now whether they hire you
or not is a different thing they might
hire you me and George can both be
exceptional actors but if they're
looking for somebody who's dashing and
handsome and clearly intelligent looking
they're gonna go with George if they
want somebody that looks a little bit uh
Rough Around the Edges they might go
with me and so that heading into a job
in the creative arts already saying well
I can't do anything about it it's just
going to be subject that's not true
everybody can sit there it's gonna be
really tough yes now if is it going to
be a hard road to hoe to make a living
doing those two things a hundred percent
that's not subjectivity that's just the
nature of the market and you throw chat
GPT and all that it's a it's it's a wild
time to be a writer it's a wild time to
be an actor right
um even the old days of residuals those
are largely gone and you're just you're
just gig to Gig to Gig it's a tough it's
a tough life and for those people that
George and I know that do this for a
living they love every second of it well
most of the seconds of it right so
um don't go into it already sour or you
won't you've got to go into it with
optimism and joy and this has to be
something that you have to do otherwise
it's going to be a tough tough slog man
right it just already feels like there's
somewhat stacked against you if you're
not already in it like correct your foot
in the door yeah it's going to be really
hard regardless but here's the thing
this idea that I'm going to use passive
income as like a launch ramp to this
career is the wrong path because you're
seeking out a shortcut that doesn't even
exist passive income is a myth
we've just all been watching too much
Tick Tock and Instagram if we think
we're just going to get all this mailbox
money that's going to float our dream
jobs it doesn't work and so what I would
do if I were you is find something that
you can sink your teeth into full time
that pays more while we get acting gigs
on the side and start to work on our
riding chops and start to submit those
and get into acting and writing groups
and improv classes and meet people and
interact that's the only path that I've
ever seen actually work so let me let me
walk you through a couple of things just
so you get the other side of this okay
George and I aren't actors we do act
like we're friends and we're not but
other than that we we're not actors but
we are on stages we are in front of
video cameras we are doing we're all
recording doing scripts all that all day
long we both write
so I remember walking out of the
building one day before what I would
call a casual shoot the following day
with Dave and a couple other
personalities
Dave Ramsey and a couple of other
personalities who were world-class
speakers been doing this for a decade or
so we're on the stage mumbling to
themselves holding a script they were
practicing
they've been on stages of six seven ten
thousand people and they're gonna do a
small event in front of a couple hundred
and they're up there practicing
also George and I both write we both
said hey would you read this for me hey
we can check something out we have
editors that we work with sometimes we
join a writers group that's just based
on studying humor so he can be funnier
and be more engaging it's a constant
practice and we're already employed this
is already our job some of the greatest
actors I know they took waiter jobs and
they practiced different accents with
different tables and they would write a
small script and memorize it themselves
and go use it with the particular person
at the at the table they were constantly
working on their craft they were not
just sitting around waiting for the
craft to come to them because it won't
writers write all the stinking time they
write blogs and they write letters and
they write journal entries and they
write chapters that's just what they do
because that's who they are if you talk
to writers that's their identity that's
what they do and so this you can't wait
for it man you got to go get it and like
George said if you get a job driving
practice your acting practice monologues
practice ideas and talk them into a
voice recorder while you're driving and
then type them out at 4 30 in the
morning the next morning that's how you
make it get a full-time gig and then in
the evening time
um go try to get commercials in your
local area I mean it's it is hard hard
everybody wants to be an actor it's a
fun life man everybody wants to be on
stage it's a fun life it's a grueling
hard one too see what I'm saying like I
love George I love that you said that
the whole
I just want to get that passive income
thing where they just mail you money
like
that happened during covet and it's not
going to happen again right yeah okay so
we're ruining your dreams here man what
are you what do you think in here
well so I'm thinking that I am I do I
have an agent and I I started writing
um some some short stories that uh that
I just I just don't know if they're any
good or if people would even want to get
a group get a writer's group my wife has
a writer's group I've got a writer's
group I've got people on the side that
read my stuff yeah get a writer's group
man yeah they'll tell you so I guess my
uh my my follow-up question would be for
someone who is almost middle-aged and
who uh hasn't had many wins in their
professional slash personal life what do
you say to someone like that who wants
to achieve something but they just feel
like they may never do it how old are
you they may never reachable I'm 37. who
told you it was too late for you
uh that's just kind of how I've
someone at some point said oh dude
you're it's too late you're 37 you'll
never make it no not no not that it's
too late but it's just never
but there's a lack of belief in Andrew
and a lack of confidence you said nah my
work No One's Gonna my work's not great
I don't think I can even do it there's
such a lack of Hope and I want to give
this job in my 40s Ken Coleman started
his job in his 40s
now we have years of work leading up to
these jobs where we were both were
writers he was doing um radio stuff he
was doing interviewing I was doing
public speaking all over the place
but we didn't start this job till until
we were in our 40s
it's never too late it's never ever ever
too late I'm gonna hook you up with some
resources number one is Ken Coleman's
book The Proximity principle to get you
connected with others in this field and
from paycheck to purpose to give you
some hope that you will get there and I
hope you call us back and let us know
how it went man thanks for the call
foreign
[Music]
ER of the Ramsey Show and you want to
dive deeper into the baby steps some of
the lingo we throw out here baby sip 3B
gazelle intensity go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button it's totally free we're
going to help you figure out the next
best step for where you're at in your
financial Journey today go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on get
started I'm George Campbell joined by Dr
John deloney this hour it's a free call
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five and Jay joins us up next in
Chicago Jay welcome welcome to the show
what's up
hi thank you for accepting my call sure
what's going on
so my question is I was wondering if it
is too late to negotiate a medical
medical collection that I already said
that I already started paying for
okay so this is already in collections
so you weren't paying on it for a while
collections bought it what's left on the
debt
it started at like
3200 and now it's down to 2300.
do you have an agreement with them of
how much you're paying each month
so the thing is I first got that medical
bill when I was like around 19 or 20.
and I'm 25 now so the memory of like how
that all got set up is pretty faint now
and I haven't like paid the day in about
two years
okay so you haven't touched the thing in
24 months
but before then you were kind of
chipping away at it
yeah I was paying a little bit at a time
on it yes have they contacted you in the
last two years
um
maybe not as maybe not more than how
many times I could count on on one hand
so it sounds like they've kind of given
up on this debt
I suppose no but well here's the thing
the longer it's been the more chance you
have of negotiating I don't think
they're just going to wipe it out it's
not going to disappear if you put your
head in the sand so you have to deal
with this but what you can do is call
them and say hey I'm sorry I know it's
been years I'm ready to be done with
this thing here's what I got I got I got
500 bucks would you take that and call
the debt good
so I have a story about this so I did
send an email about it which they have a
response so I have to call them and they
did acknowledge that they did receive
the email but they said because of the
who the Creditor was they weren't
allowed to uh negotiate you know due to
the fact of who the Creditor is I've
never heard that who's the creator I've
never heard it either but when I called
the Creditor like it was true
okay well either way you got to pay this
thing if they're not willing to
negotiate I still want it out of my life
because it's been looming in yours for a
long long time
did you get some Medical Care done what
did you have what did you have done
and you know crazy it costed you know 3
200 to get that resolved and
um yeah that's all I had done I just
went to go get that checked out
so can I flip this around and
put this in both of your hands at the
same time is that cool
sure you're not gonna like me but that's
okay is that cool like can we still be
friends go for it
just going to a local ER or a dock on
the box in the corner it can be
outrageously expensive
outrageous insanely expensive especially
um if you're a college student and you
don't have any other Alternatives right
and
if we go back to when you're 18 19 or 20
you were really sick and you walked into
place and you said will you help me and
they said yeah we will and was it
expensive yes was it worth what they
gave you I don't know who knows I don't
even know what the procedure was and and
I don't really want to know
but there's something to be said for hey
when I needed help y'all were there
I'll pay my bill and now I'm 25 I'm 26.
I'm this thing's been hanging around
forever it's time for me to just be an
adult and say thank you even though I
think what you charged me was 10 times
what what you actually did maybe they
gave you a high five and a lollipop and
said go get them kid and then they
charge you 3200 bucks right who knows
what they did but there's something to
be said for I went and utilized a
service it helped I'm better
I'm gonna pay my bill even though I
don't agree with it I'm going to be wise
and informed moving forward but let's
just pay this thing and get out of our
life
you're going to have a soul tax you're
going to make yourself nuts calling
these folks emailing them waiting for
the response getting them to call you
back and because their their job is to
tell you no forever and ever and ever
amen just pay the bill and move on with
your life
that's my recommendation that's what I
would do do you have the money much
um I can do it but the thing is like I
just really don't want to especially if
there's options but let's pretend
there's no option and you pay what you
were billed do you have the money
yes okay and some more where are you at
financially right now do you have any
other debt
uh just
just
good for you what's your income
I'm sorry what's your income now
right now it's about just for now it's
about maybe 35 36 a year okay and you've
got more than 2 300 in the bank
yes
you can give it one last college try but
if they say no just say all right I'm
ready to pay this thing in full and get
everything in writing yeah that's the
two big rules do not under any
circumstance give them your checking
account number because they're going to
say just give us your number and we'll
direct deposit it or we'll direct uh
draft it do not do that and make sure
you get a read receipt in writing so I
would get a money order go down to a
post office your local bank get a money
order and I would mail this with a read
receipt on it so that you've got proof
that they received this thing and then
you're home free and you might sit at
home and be like Matt I can't believe
you are free you're finally done with
this stuff
thank you for the college I appreciate
it all right let's take one more this
hour from nalesh right here locally in
Nashville Tennessee Nilesh welcome to
the show
hey how are you guys thank you for
taking my call sure what's going on with
you
so I am 26 years old I currently work in
HR for a company here in Nashville
and I make 55 000 a year
um currently have 35 000 in student loan
debt uh I recently got into a doctorate
program for pharmacy school and for four
years tuition will come up to roughly
around 175. what school what school did
you get into
Lipscomb excellent
um and so my question is
do I pursue a doctor or program with the
hopeful outcome of a better salary and
better future lifestyle but will make me
go into at most two hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt or do I
stay where I'm at like I guess like for
me I know what my dreams are and I know
what my goals are but then also looking
at the real life Financial practical
side of things I have to make I have to
consider
um am I just digging myself into a
deeper hole or do I pursue these goals
that I've had I'll let George talk to
the math part of it here's what I want
to tell you you and I are both here in
Nashville lipscomb's program is
excellent Belmont's program is world
class those are great Pharmacy programs
and there's probably several other
programs around here the world needs
better pharmacists who are informed who
aren't just pill pushers who teach
people at the counter and care about
their their patients and clients we need
them okay and you cannot afford this
it's a hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars
right and so yeah I want I I have
friends and colleagues at both of those
schools incredible opportunities and you
can't afford it man
I think we need to see what the other
options are and that might mean we wait
we pay off our student loan debt we
start to stack up some cash we get
scholarships maybe you're married by
then we have dual income and we start to
be able to cash flow this thing but
right now going 200 000 into debt and on
the other side hoping we make enough to
pay the bills and get by and one day pay
the student loans off you're just
trading uh for another burden and the
tuition is 175. but you have living
costs for three to four years you've got
eating costs you've got all sorts of
other things that add up and students
coming out with Pharmacy degrees 250 300
350 in the hole is not an anomaly that's
not a weird thing that happens it's
rather common
I'd love to see you crank this that
thirty thousand dollars to loan debt out
you're only making 55 and so I get
things are tight especially here in
Nashville I mean it's an expensive place
to live
it may be that jumping to this next
thing four years from now isn't the
right move right this second and by the
way my mom graduated from her PhD at 57.
you have plenty of time my brother
plenty of time just do it the right way
um do it the right way and don't don't
hit don't hinge your entire life on one
thing yeah this this doesn't mean your
life is over if you put pause on this
thing to do it the right way move slow
do it when you have the cash you'll walk
into that Pharmacy uh program with a lot
more peace yes hey stay on the line
we're going to send you our friends uh
Anthony O'Neill's book debt-free degree
and he'll help you get there my friend
good call that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show in the books
[Music]
Journey we've got a Weekly Newsletter
that gives you helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the frogs
Moving and Storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsey
personality George Campbell join this
hour my fellow Ramsey personality Dr
John deloney host of the Dr John deloney
show which has just been going zoom zoom
as they say John so be sure to check
that out on podcast and YouTube uh if
you're a fan of John which I assume you
are who says that
I don't know it just felt right in the
moment to be all right yeah good it did
as they say and I've joined the ranks
now John as a fellow YouTuber with my
new YouTube channel and I will say it
feels as good as they say it said it
would you're crushing all of us when I
tell my family I'm like I'm a YouTuber
now it feels I get a newfound respect oh
no I've that's that's how my kids bring
me back to Earth but that's what all the
kids want to be these days so it
actually makes me cool
I think that's an important thing for
you to continue to repeat to yourself
over and over it makes me cool with
teenagers yeah that's you know things
aren't going well for you but your show
is going fantastic man tell us about it
it is yeah we've we have about 14
episodes we do Monday Wednesday Fridays
it's funny they put memes and clips and
it's snark and sarcasm with the Ramsay
principles that you know and love and my
show can get kind of dark and it's an
hour long yours is pretty quick these
are like seven eight nine ten minute
videos that we're putting out there and
the team's been doing it I mean really
the fact that people are commenting
going the editing is amazing tells you
how incredible the team is behind the
scenes making this happen so our editors
here are second to none go check it out
we uh we we hit 30 000 subscribers in 30
days John
yeah it's been fun the comments has been
nine subscribers after 30 days so that's
fantastic
that's when James was running the show
most of them were the team it's my mom
just hitting refresh over and over again
well now you've got hundreds of
thousands and it's a it really is a
great show I appreciate that and I mean
that which I rarely do and George does
call in the show under pseudonyms and so
only way I can get John to take me
seriously correct well we're answering
your questions on today's show triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number to call Connor is in Salt
Lake City Connor welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey thanks for having me absolutely how
can we help
yeah so my wife and I were currently on
baby step six
um but we're looking to move in the next
couple years we're just wondering if we
should be paying extra on our mortgage
or if we should just be saving that
money what would you be saving the money
for
uh I don't know down payment on a house
we have our emergency fund obviously but
you know I feel comfortable more
comfortable with more money in the bank
I have so
so with your home equity what does that
look like right now versus what you owe
it's like how much Equity we have yeah
what's left on the mortgage and what's
the house worth
so there's 275 left on the house and
it's worth about 450. okay
I'll tell you what I did and uh you know
everyone plans on moving at some point
probably if they're in their 20s 30s 40s
50s even and so I like to look at this
as a four savings plan where I go if I
have a pile of money over here we might
go oh you know what we gotta upgrade the
the old thing we got to do the
renovation we got to go on the vacation
and all of a sudden the money that would
have been going towards helping you
build wealth uh in your home equity is
now going towards other things so as
just a human who is fallible I like to
just go let's pay down the mortgage it's
not disappearing it's going to be in the
home equity when we go to sell and then
you just roll all of that money
into the next house
yeah yeah that makes sense that way you
can't access it
how much of Conor how much of
your concern about having a pile of cash
in addition to your emergency fund is
just what's in the air right now
you know you got
every News Channel trying to scare you
to death you've got every nonsense
influencer telling you it's all coming
down we're gonna be trading cigarettes
and rocks and coffee for like how much
of it is that there's just a lot in the
air right now A Bank fails and it just
as Warren Buffett says fear is
contagious how much of it's that you're
starting to get nervous
yeah I'd say it's probably 50 I don't
know I've always just been a saver and
like have have money in the bank but
yeah I mean I watched the Ramsey Show
and people calling about the banks and
the US dollars so I'd say that's
definitely fueling that so desire to
have more cash on hand I want to tell
you that the idea of the the feeling you
think you're gonna have
like let's just imagine you're sitting
on your couch and you imagined I have a
hundred thousand dollars in my checking
account
like that you can just you can just
picture that
and you imagine how you would feel
my promise to you is
if you were sitting there across the
dinner table from your wife and you all
have no house payment
that feeling is infinitely more powerful
because if the US dollar goes away and
we're trading water and cigarettes and
turtle shells for food or whatever they
think or we're just suddenly going to go
to bitcoin and beanie babies or whatever
it is
a paid for home that nobody can take
from you
is a level of security that you don't
even know your body needs
okay so there's something about I get
the math and I get the hey it's all
coming down and I do get the fear is
contagious I I'm with you I get nervous
about that stuff I'm just cosmically
blessed that I get to sit by Dave a
couple times a week and I'm like Hey
we're good right he's like we're good
and so uh and he's Supernatural about
that all right he just has a piece about
him because he understands and if it was
going sideways he'd let us know
so
most people don't get that which I
understand what I want to tell you is
there is another level it's like a it's
like an elevator Open Secret elevator
opens up beneath your home another level
of Peace when you and your wife have
paid off a home and nobody can take it
from you and you can kind of do whatever
you want you want to sell it cool and
hey it has 450 000 in equity I mean it's
450 worth 450 000 you pay it off and
let's say it goes down to 300. it just
it almost Cuts in half
that would stink
and you'd still have three hundred
thousand dollars to to do life with if
you sold your house and wanted to move
see what I'm saying it's just another
level of peace and so
um I I can't recommend enough man I get
all the smoke and mirrors that's out
there and all the screaming and yelling
and fires and all I get all that
there's something that we have seen over
and over and over and experienced
pay your house off man just get that
sucker out of your life knock it out and
um be able to sit back and then go now
we can start making some different
decisions
yeah no and that's honestly the goal is
just like I said we're looking to move
so I I know I'm not going to get that
275 000 mortgage paid off before we move
so I mean but you'll get that money bit
off
yeah yeah I know I will what's your
household income
I think about 100 a year
and that's just you are you married
I'm married yeah I just worked my wife
stays home okay cool
so when it comes time to move man just
roll over that equity and you'll have a
lot of peace and the other thing is you
gotta unfollow and turn off the the
dudes out there going it's so dumb to
pay off your house man you can make so
much more if you invest that money in
the market and I'm going the market was
down 18 last year like where are they
getting this free magical money
guaranteed and so I know that's out
there and that's probably a part of this
equation is you're going I could make
more with my savings account it's not
Apple's apples there's no Freedom like
having a paid for a house
and the guys who say it's dumb to pay
off your house don't have paid for
houses they don't know what that freedom
tastes like and feels like so uh you
know what to do man keep chugging away
at that mortgage and even if you don't
pay it off it's a great four savings
plan to help me avoid stupid decisions
appreciate the call more of your calls
coming up triple eight eight two five
five two two five this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
time
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney hey if you're listening to this
show I hope you're enjoying what you're
hearing and if you do if you like the
show please consider doing a few things
that cost you nothing but take a maybe a
like a brain calorie and that is
consider hitting the Subscribe button
leaving us a review wherever you're
listening and sharing this with a friend
who might enjoy it that helps a ton it
helps the algorithms love us which
really just means we get to spread more
hope and make more impact yeah actually
George I think it's important to note
like yeah it makes us feel good and
helps our numbers that's cool but if you
are like me and you're frustrated when
you see people spending money they don't
have not because you're high and mighty
but because you know what it's doing to
their family you know it's doing to our
economy
the more you like And subscribe and put
five star reviews in there the more this
thing kicks up into more algorithms and
gets in front of more people it's a no
it it costs no money to get this message
out in front of other people and so you
don't have to say anything you don't
have to proselytize about it all you
have to do is like And subscribe and it
just kicks it up more and more and more
spell all the toxic craps out there
right love it let's get to the calls we
got Joe in Lexington Kentucky up next
Joe welcome to the show
hey guys how's it going great how are
you
oh pretty good
um I have a long drawn-out story I'm
gonna try to condense down as much as I
can because it starts
years ago
um
my wife and I currently we're not in any
debt other than our house but
I still want to go through the baby
steps
um you know we've uh okay let me preface
this with saying
I'll try to get introduce the Baby Says
Baby Steps 15 20 years ago and she
sought me on it argued that we didn't
make enough money to do it continue to
be heavily in debt you know I work two
jobs to make against me you know of
course she works as well
uh then my father passed away in 2020
and left us left me a decent amount of
money
and
that was the only reason we were able to
pay anything off and
we did under the unfortunate
circumstances obviously
um
some of the money that we had left over
my wife you know I kept it in savings
and my wife kind of used it as a piggy
bank
you know whatever we went over never
remember our expenses
she kept pulling from it and I explained
to her that you know it's it's it's not
an infinite amount of money it's going
to disappear if you keep doing that and
she just she continued to do it so
I ended up taking half of the money
putting it putting it in my own savings
account
and saying you can do whatever you want
with your ass that's left you know I'm
I'm keeping a savings so we you know we
have you know I'm trying to keep it as
an emergency fund
um
of course that didn't go over well but
you know we
recently within the last couple weeks
I've tried to stress that I wanted to be
able to save money create like a full
um emergency fund save money for our
kids college funds
and she's she just she fights me on it
constantly and
says that we don't make enough money
to do these steps and I just want to
know
is if she is totally against it is there
any way to get her on board
with you know the baby steps so Joe I
would tell you there's a lot going on
here this has nothing to do with money
and I think you're correct this is a
marriage that's in a lot of trouble am I
right
uh I I would I would agree yes and I
think there's an extra layer now
that she has burned through what you
would consider holy money right sacred
money money my dad left us that we had
to spend a huge chunk off to pay off
last year's meals and last five years
ago vehicles
an old man bailed me out one more time
and I put this money and we're gonna
hold it and it's Gonna Keep Us Safe in
the future and she's buying shoes and
clothes and whatever with it
that's correct that's not about money
man that's about two people that I'm
afraid are
sit four inches away from each other on
the couch every night but y'all are 4
000 miles away in what your marriage
looks like in priorities in dreams and
hopes and mental health issues all that
stuff
most of the time let me just back it out
I think um George correct me if I'm
wrong but on the millionaire study there
there is is very few if none
people who became very wealthy fighting
a spouse the whole way I think the date
of the day was that has has spoken about
and I don't know it off top of my head
like like Dave like like you and Dave
and uh do George but
a couple that works together in
Partnership is virtually Unstoppable not
only financially but with just about
anything
they do cancer together they do passing
of parents together they do problems
with kids together they do ever they
just ride or die man and conversely
spouses that drag on each other create a
Cascade of problems of one of those is
financial so no I don't think you can
just create this alternative Universe
where you
get you out of debt and you suddenly
just create this alt Universe I mean
it's just a further way to drive a wedge
between you and your wife can I ask you
a hard question
sure
um
why has she
created an alternative life that does
not include you
are you a guy who's always got a scheme
or always got a plan or always like Hey
we're going to try this and try this
um or is she just really immature and
undisciplined
she's she's undisciplined she she she's
not extravagant in her lifestyle but
you know her thing is that well I'm
tired of giving things up there you go
I've had to give up so much and so
that's and I have to hear that all the
time can I give you a hard word for that
childish
exactly I have a seven-year-old daughter
and that's what she says and it's
developmentally appropriate for her to
say it I don't even get mad at her she's
seven
right but the fact that I've had to give
up everything is going to cost y'all all
of it
and so I the only way I've seen to be
successful George I've been here the
only way I've seen it be successful
is not for you to talk about the Dave
Ramsey plan or Total Money Makeover or
financial peace
but just sit down in front of your wife
you all go out somewhere get out of your
environment at your home because we just
act different there and I always tell
people to go to breakfast because it's
early in the morning and it's not I
don't have to go to bed or anything like
that go to breakfast go to lunch and let
her know hey we're gonna have a like a
big scope conversation
and you start that conversation not
throwing grenades at her
all of the conversation is I language I
am scared to death that I'm about to
lose my marriage I'm scared to death
about our financial future so much that
I can't breathe
I'm scared of looking my kids in the eye
when they know Granddad left them a lot
of money and they've got no college fund
at all
I can't breathe I'm so scared
okay would you help would you be
interested in healing this marriage
because if not we need to have a harder
conversation
right but you see what I'm saying all of
this is about you because if you start
being like hey you don't spend money
this way you don't do this you don't do
this she has to put up a brick wall to
defend herself against you
she has her whole life probably and I
know she's got her own story she's not
here to defend herself and I don't want
to be in the business of talking bad
about a man's wife but you've got to go
first and and and risk her looking at
you saying I'm not doing any of this
crap
and then you're gonna have some hard
decisions to make
all right I think if you lead with that
vulnerability Joe it's going to change
the conversation she's gonna this is a
different Joe he's not coming at me he's
not going with the what and the how he's
talking about the why he's sharing his
fears he's sharing his dreams and then
once we have those laid out and you hear
her side what are your fears what are
your dreams what's driving this spending
what's the root cause well then we can
develop a plan and the plan becomes this
is what we both agreed on is our shared
Vision our shared goals and then it's
not one person against the other hang on
the line here I'm going to send you a
free uh Financial Peace University for
free and the every dollar app and The
Total Money Makeover book y'all can do
this together so I'm gonna set you up
and if you get to it after she agrees to
begin repairing your marriage this can
be one of the tools that you'll use to
get back on the same page hang on the
line we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
a home is one of the biggest decisions
of your life you need a partner like
Churchill Mortgage Churchill is one of
the highest rated lenders in the country
and their Ramsay trusted because they do
what's right for you Churchill works
with you to build a mortgage the Ramsay
way one that doesn't bust your budget
sets you up for financial success and
helps you get out of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five so John
this article uh it got my attention
because we've talked about sports
betting a lot on this show but this
headline was interesting sports betting
is the new oxycon
I think that's interesting the a really
excellent way of explaining the problem
here
so that everybody's clear your state
governments are profiting
off the complete and total collapse
of the state citizens Mental Health
when it comes to the issues with sports
betting especially you're able to just
do it with your phone wherever you
happen to be you don't have to just you
can't go to a casino and you can just do
it whenever and states are raking in
this money
um so 33 States it's NDC it's now legal
believable soon to be four more six more
are debating legislation and we see
these sports betting app I've never seen
advertising so aggressive from
DraftKings win bet Rivers FanDuel
Caesars and there's a bunch more and now
professional sports leagues are going oh
my gosh we can make so much money
through advertising and betting
Partnerships if we take advantage of
this yeah I love the way Brian hatch
who's a recovering gambling addict and
now an addiction counselor in
Connecticut he writes the industry is
profiting off people with an addiction
the same way the Sackler family profited
off opioids opioids were pushed by the
drug companies and doctors relentlessly
gambling is now pushed by the interest
industry and
we're the government we're here to help
your state government right so you can't
even blame it on the you know the evil
drug companies now it's the state
government the same people who provide
your roads and your cops and your
firefighters those are the folks saying
like hey man have you thought about
taking a sports bet when they know how
addictive this is how destructive this
is and now with cell phones there there
is no breaks there are no breaks there
used you had to get up go get cash and
go to a casino then they put ATMs in
casinos amid a little bit easier and
your bank Cuts you off and then credit
came even the credit cards would cut you
now you just sit there with your phones
man and go and go and go and it's
Madness so it feels more dangerous
because it's socially acceptable it's
like oh it's innocent John it's Sports
we're having a good time with the
buddies and it it actually is it's gonna
be a lot of fun and it unless you got a
problem with it and that's it
listen man no one thinks they have the
problem they go well John I mean all my
buddies do this we have a good time and
we leave yeah sometimes I'm down a few
hundred bucks whatever
what do you say to that guy yeah it's a
mess it reminds me of
um folks who struggle with
um addiction right if you struggle with
cocaine one of the first things are with
alcohol one of the first things they
tell you to do the first lines of
defense is you got to change your
environment you got to change the places
you go the people you hang out with you
have to avoid alcohol you have to avoid
places where cocaine is right
if you struggle with disordered eating
it's infinitely more challenging because
you can't avoid food
you have to make peace with it in your
body it's an infinitely more complex
process it's hard man it's hard it's
what's why Eating Disorders is a
disorder eating is one of the most
deadly mental health issues there is
so similarly there used to be guard
rails
it was a it was an event it was a trip
and you could blow your family's Savings
in a weekend and that's about where it
stopped
now it you just have this phone with you
all the time and so you've got to make
peace with this
and then you've got these government
officials who just keep dollar sign
dollar sign dollar sign dollar sign
which by the way doing a bang-up job of
spending what they got as is
and they are just profiting off people
who are falling apart if you look at the
the number of people calling addiction
hotlines for gambling it is astronomical
when you look at the number of people
who are are reporting losses
astronomical it's just it's madness
madness madness yeah and the math on it
is extra sad I mean there's professional
bookies out there and you're thinking
like I'm gonna beat these guys I'm gonna
get the spread I'm gonna take these odds
and in the long run you always lose and
you've got to spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars to see any real
money from this and so if it's just
innocent fun go spend it on a great meal
and just enjoy sports for what it is
versus then adding this layer of peer
pressure and addiction on top of that or
if you're with if if your finances are
good and your buddies are putting ten
dollars on a thing or I mean again I
sound like I'm talking on both sides of
my mouth they're they're
the the recipe for this to get out of
control is so significant and man I
don't want to be I'm not a funny daddy
like have a good time right but we all
have folks in our life that we know hey
I'm gonna be respectful that guy's two
years sober we're not bringing alcohol
to this thing everybody y'all are coming
over to my house we're not drinking
everybody just I need y'all to know that
awesome he's one of the gang it's hard
to know that now and everybody's got a
cell phone with him 24 7 365. this this
whole thing makes me sick man it makes
me it really is gross I think it's going
to be the next kind of epidemic in the
in the addiction World well it's going
to be equally an academic epidemic
you're gonna have a group of citizens
that are completely melted down and they
were cheered and clapped on by their
local representatives and you're going
to have government officials who are not
great at windfalls they get these what
is it New Jersey Bettors have waged
nearly 35 billion dollars and the states
made 300 million bucks off of it in
Pennsylvania Bettors have waged almost
20 billion generating more than 380
million dollars the government is going
to come to see this as expected Revenue
and it's going to be and they're going
to take it out on Cops we can't afford
police officers and we can't afford to
fix your roads
because we don't have any more people to
sacrifice it's just Madness man it's
really really frustrating for me having
sat with folks who are struggling with
gambling addiction
it I mean it's enraging it's enraging
yeah well definitely seek help if if
that's you if you have the
self-awareness to go I got a problem
please please seek help it's out there
all right let's go to the phones Nick
joins us over in Grand Rapids Nick
welcome to the show
hi uh thank you for taking my call
um I just want to know if I should
switch jobs from a job I like to a job
in the same field but with better pay
and benefits this feels like a home run
what's stopping you
um I guess I just really like the job
that I'm at right now and it's kind of
on the ladder and I want to be on you
know I want to own my own construction
company at a certain point and right now
I'm learning every facet of construction
and in this new job it'd be more
specified uh and not so much every
everything you know we think it would
slow down your goal of running your own
company if you took this new job
I think it could I think it could
because there's certain things like like
for instance framing a house
um I wouldn't you know I'm learning that
right now but I don't know how to
completely and in this new job I
wouldn't be doing a hardly any framing
all right
how old are you
I'm 21. and what's the pay bump
um I guess not and I have an interview
next week um so that's gonna be
specified but it's anywhere from it's
probably at most a four dollar an hour
pay bump
okay but I but right now I have no
benefits that the government and the job
that I would be going to has 401K
um a lot more paid time off uh in health
insurance stuff like that that's big but
you're talking probably an 8K pay bump
plus the benefits that you don't have
any right now and so you're paying for
those out of pocket do you have health
insurance
yeah um it's actually subsidized because
my wife is currently staying at home so
it's like 30 bucks for my son and I okay
a month what are you going to be doing
in your new job
um it's kind of like
I'd be like the wrap-up guy kind of I'm
going through that house putting on the
finishing a couple finishing touches
like cleaning up a good bit
um you know and occasionally doing more
involved stuff
so how hard would it be to do this new
job
and also go above and beyond show up a
little bit early have somebody teach you
some things stay a little bit late to
have somebody teach you some things I
have met some of the most generous
teachers in my life on construction
sites those Tradesmen love to teach
people their craft because they're so
proud of the work they do
is that possible yeah I think it could
be
um for sure I get I guess I'd just be
concerned about the you know
specifically like framing a house and
stuff like that like that yeah a lot of
Hands-On work you're exactly right
you're exactly right here's what I want
you to know you're 21.
either job you take if I'm you I would
take the I would take the pay increase I
would and I would work my butt off to
learn and learn and learn in my spare
time know this the work you put in in
your 20s and halfway through your 30s
will be what Cascades you through the
back half of your life work like crazy
right now
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
baloney this hour call us up at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
listen sometimes you gotta buckle down
and sacrifice if you want to make
progress with your money but today is
not one of those days because you we're
giving you the chance to win some of
Dave's money in the Ramsay cash giveaway
all month long you can enter to win up
to 500 bucks or the grand prize of three
thousand dollars all you got to do is go
to ramseysolutions.com giveaway and you
can enter daily which will increase your
chances of winning and there's no
purchase necessary but you got to be 18
or older in order to win and today keeps
getting better because the 10 sale is
also back and I love a good deal and uh
you know inflation's not hitting us here
at Ramsey Solutions so we can still
offer you some of our best selling tools
and products like Dr John deloney's book
own your pass change your future for the
first time in the ten dollar sale ever
that's amazing and there's nothing
better than being on commission and your
boss saying hey I'm gonna start selling
it feels so good so it's for the good of
the People John that's right buy two and
we have your John deloney's questions
for humans conversation cards for just
10 bucks each as well it also includes
The Total Money Makeover baby steps
millionaires some of Dave's best sellers
there that will lay out the plan help
you pay off debt and build lasting
wealth but don't wait these deals are
going to be gone soon go shop the 10
sale today at ramseysolutions.com store
and don't forget to enter the giveaway
at ramseysolutions.com giveaway all
right let's go to the phones Matthew is
up next in Salt Lake City Matthew what's
going on
hi
um so I
I and my fiance we're in uh some debt
and I was just wondering um I've been
hearing about e-commerce and I was just
wondering uh what you guys what your
take is on us trying to get into
e-commerce
to pay it off what do you think
e-commerce is
so I don't quite have my opinion on it
quite yet I love it it's like hey so
we're gonna do this internet thing where
we get a million dollars can we do that
yeah no I I get that is this Drop
Shipping what are you talking about here
yeah like Drop Shipping I've looked into
that um I've also been like having
people approach me at work and they keep
offering these like sit Downs to go and
talk that's like that's called
multi-level marketing yeah sophisticated
Avon dude or uh essential oils
let me guess they didn't tell you
exactly what the business is but it's a
great opportunity and you can make some
extra money right
uh that was a couple of them yeah
those ones I know are not the real ones
you know here's what George and I will
do for you if you mail us five thousand
dollars we problem to make promise to
make good choices with that money and
you may be entitled to yeah don't do
that don't do that how much debt debt
y'all have
so she has eighteen thousand dollars in
student loans and two thousand dollars
in credit card I have a let's see twelve
thousand dollars on my car and about I
want to say two three thousand dollars
on my credit cards total that's
including medical bills okay talking 35
total yeah and you guys are about to get
married what's your household income
going to be
so I'm making about a little over 20 000
a year right now and uh she is so she's
doing part-time right now at a newspaper
and now she's going to be switching over
to doing Walmart
um working there full time during the
summer until she goes back to school
um are you in school as well
I am not no I chose I'm like I don't
feel like going into bet for something
that I have no idea what I want to do
yet what do you do for a living
I sell cell phones at Walmart
okay I think we need to get a better
paying job can you just work the retail
part of Walmart because if you're
working full-time you got to be making
more than 20K
yeah that's
yeah it's uh it's like like 22
000 or something like that and yeah
that's like 10 bucks an hour you're
worth double than that you can go to
McDonald's and literally double your
income
so is that I'm I've been with this
company for like two years and they are
taking your soul
you're about to pay like you're about to
get married you're making 20 grand a
year
what is your loyalty to a company paying
you minimum wage and why is that loyalty
greater than the loyalty to your new
wife and to the loyalty to you
you're worth more than this
yeah I'm getting paid um so I'm gonna
pay 14 an hour and this is like the job
that I met my fiance at so does that
make it special is it like a yes it
doesn't mean I have to work at Arby's
exactly but if you're making 14 an hour
you got to be making more than 20K a
year if you're doing that full time
yeah I don't um yeah we're doing it I I
don't know it's very weird because last
year I got laid off from the other
company and we started up with a new
company
I think you guys need to find careers
instead of jobs and that's long longer
term because you guys are young how old
are you I'm 22 she's 23. okay once we
find careers it's going to help pay off
this debt but e-commerce is not this no
you're not in a position right I just
did a video on this on my new YouTube
channel it's called Savvy or scammy the
truth about e-commerce side hustles go
watch it it's nine minutes and I hope it
talks you off the ledge of thinking that
you're gonna be the next guy
construction money construction
companies make good money that doesn't
mean I should go start a construction
business because I know nothing about it
and I have zero passion for it I I I
would love to see you ask to meet with a
manager at the Walmart where you work do
you work for a company within a Walmart
is that the deal
I work for premium Wireless there you go
okay yeah we're a separate company from
Walmart officially I need you to hear me
say something you are being taking
advantage of
they are taking advantage of a 22 year
old guy and they say things like loyalty
and yeah bro and all the opportunities
you are worth more than what they are
paying you I would love to see you stop
by the management desk at the Walmart
where you work and say I'm interested in
a management track could we talk
how much are the things that I'm hoping
to get no no don't hope to get go get
them
okay go get them and they the what's the
worst they can tell you is hey man
you're probably too young or you need to
start stocking in the back and that only
pays 18 bucks an hour unless you work at
night then it only pays 27 bucks an hour
and then your eyes are gonna pop out of
your head and you'll be like wow I can
make 45
000 slinging boxes overnight as a 22
year old yup
yeah I don't know I just
yeah because with this company that I'm
with I'm hoping to eventually move up to
management positions but I guess what
you guys are trying to tell me is don't
just want it or no don't just hope for
it go get it no that's what we're
telling you you're being taken advantage
of oh
yeah and listen if they sat down and
said hey we're paying you twenty
thousand dollars a year we're gonna grow
five grand because we're a small company
we're gonna give you this responsibility
we're gonna move you here we're gonna
move you here I might tell you go get it
I've taken a pay cut several times in my
career to go to another job but the map
forward was very clear
what they're doing to you is taking
taking advantage of a young guy
who is very loyal who doesn't have any
additional education
and they are growing out with you so you
will stick around
that's what they're doing
and it it and you can hear it in my
voice it makes me mad that they're doing
that to you more importantly they're
making you feel like you're one of the
gang and one day you're going to be in a
management position I promise you
they're not making 20 grand
I promise you they're tripling or
quadrupling what you're making
yeah my uh my buddy who's the manager
over me he's making forty thousand
dollars a year I think you can do better
than that in the same building where you
go to work every day
so I think we need to do some soul
searching here and I'm going to help you
out with that Matthew number one I'm
going to send you my friend Ken
Coleman's assessment the get clear
assessment because I think right now
you're just going at whatever the thing
is in front of you I think we need to
pause and go what was Matthew wired to
do created to do what lights him up and
whatever that thing is you got an
entrepreneurial Spirit go chase that and
do it the right way over time we're also
going to send you Ken's book from
paycheck to purpose to help you get
there because I think you're worth more
than that and as a newlywed couple I
want to see you guys win I want to see
you pay off this debt so should we send
them FPU too John I I yes I'm gonna send
you FPU
um
that's our wedding gift
um FPU and every other AD but listen to
me you get married in nine days
you're going to look at somebody on a
stage and you're gonna say I do forever
if you're gonna make that kind of
Declaration in Covenant and commitment
you have to put her in your future ahead
of I don't know man it may work out bro
that nonsense is for kids and that
nonsense ends today
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it
[Music]
foreign
co-host of the Ramsey show did you know
over 18
people listen to the Ramsey show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell joined by my friend Dr John
baloney this hour and we are taking your
calls a triple eight eight two five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about life money The Pursuit of
Happiness relationships boundaries
mental health it's all happening right
here on the Ramsay show that's a very
ambitious show you've just outlined
listen we gotta Aim High
aim for the Stars in Your Land among the
moon or something like that isn't that
the quest yeah that was cool and your
grandma stitched it into a pillow that
was cool I saw it at TJ Maxx all right I
love that you were at TJ Maxx we should
probably spend some time on that I'm
always like to take a call Martha joins
us up first in Greenville South Carolina
Martha welcome to the Ramsay show
hi guys hi George hi John it's a
pleasure to be on the show I was lucky
enough to attend smart conference in
April and I loved the entire weekend oh
thank you I'm glad you could join us for
that while you're on the phone will you
just settle something who was better me
or Joy I'm just kidding don't do that
don't do that but Hey listen because you
were just kind after this Call's over I
want you to hang on the line I'm going
to send you a couple of decks of
questions for humans we're going to take
care of you thank you so much for saying
something nice it's awesome
all right so what's your question
buttering you up Martha all right let's
see if we can
he is okay here's my question I have
been following the Ramsay way for about
a year I've paid off 53 000 in debt
which includes Home Credit way to go
thank you which includes some credit
card debt um however I am a director of
sales for a company so I travel often
for work typically about 27 business
trips a year obviously air flights
rental cars entertaining clients you've
kind of got to use a credit card for all
of that now I I expense it I get
reimbursed within the 30 days
I just don't know how to
then also use that within the daily
budgeting app the everyday app
right now what I do is I pretend the
credit card doesn't exist and I pretend
the reimbursement doesn't exist I kind
of just treat my everyday app like my
personal life and I treat that credit
card and any of those travel expenses as
if they don't exist but I don't know if
that's the best way to monitor it I
don't know if that's the best thing to
do so does your does your boss expect
you to spend your own money up front
correct how lame is that that's
ridiculous cards why yeah
just the way the company is what an
absolute scam like they're they're
running their company on your back
yeah for our travels that's so stupid so
just to to clear up any any
misconception what you just said all
those things entertain clients go stay
in hotels get rental cars get flights we
all do that with debit cards here at the
office
I love Dave's statement and by the way
Dave doesn't ask me to spend my own
money doing the job that he hired me to
do he fronts the money because it's his
company it's like him providing tools so
I can do my job but I love the way he
says this and it's such a great line he
said he's always had buddies who also
run businesses who say I can't believe
you give all your employees or a big
chunk of your leadership team or whoever
debit cards access to the company
checking account and he says I can't
believe you hire people that you trust
so little
that you don't trust him with that they
shouldn't be walking in your building
right but I am I'm getting onto your
boss and your boss isn't on the phone
right so this is like a practical thing
so sorry I I'm kind of in a mood today
George yeah he's on something yeah and
so here's the thing Martha have you
tried to have a conversation with your
leadership and go Hey listen I this
money is real and it's coming from my
account and it's just too much to manage
and I'm uncomfortable with this
situation either give me a corporate
card that I can use that's not tied to
my name and my credit or uh you give me
petty cash or you call ahead and and you
make all these payments happen before I
go on these trips
because they can book the travel for you
right yeah it's a it's a great question
um I did a couple of years ago and the
comp and we were told by the executive
team no we're not doing that I will say
that while our while our CEO is still
the same CEO our executive team has
changed so I very well could approach
that question with our new executive
team and see what happens yeah and
you're you said you're using your
personal credit card right now correct
correct so what's the difference if you
tried to use a personal debit card to do
all this
there really isn't any what do you mean
especially since I do have I mean you're
right but the point is you're right when
I personally travel I book hotels I book
rental cars I do all the things that you
mentioned and I do it with a debit card
I just to like
card means the money straight out of
checking where the credit card it goes
there and then I get the reimbursement
and I pay it so I'm not taking my money
how about this tell them hey I don't own
credit cards you cut yours up you say I
don't own credit cards and I don't have
all this money sitting in my checking
account to front for travel
that's an option and listen there it
there is like let's think of
construction companies there are some
construction companies that you show up
to site and they've got all the tools
for you and there are some jobs where
they say you have to bring your own
tools or you can't work here that's
that's a that's a reality okay I don't
like it that's a that's a that's a
truthful place that's a truthful
statement so let's take let's pretend
you go talk to your supervisors and they
say hey we ran up the flagpole it ain't
happening
um the same rules are going to apply
um there's a couple of things that I do
and I don't George I don't know if you
do this this personally but I when I
book travel I use a site called
privacy.com and what that is is I can
put my debit card into that site and I
don't have any affiliation with them
they have no affiliation with the Ramsey
shows it's just a free ad for them but I
put my card in and every time I go to a
hotel they give me another card and I
can create a new card and a new card and
a new card so that the hotel never has
my debit card the and I can put the
limit on how much they can pull from it
and it makes it gives me endless amounts
of cards and the service is free it's
amazing
but okay so if somebody ever hacks into
that I'm toast but until then no none of
these online vendors none of the
restaurants none of none of those folks
have my actual debit card and that's it
that's a privacy concern that I have and
I share that but that's how I that's how
I navigate the world that way the second
thing is is you might want to create a
separate checking account think of it
like a business account if you had a
side hustle create a separate checking
account put ten thousand dollars in that
account and that is the money you spend
to entertain clients and you get
reimbursed and I want you to hang
closely on the words you said earlier
that feels like my money whereas the
credit card doesn't the credit card's
your money too okay you are just Robin
Peter to pay Paul it's an illusion and
it's gonna hurt a lot more and it's
gonna make that conversation with your
supervisor a little more poignant
because that's my money out of my
checking account it feels different
right
yeah yeah I think they can easily front
load the money into an account for you
to spend from but they probably won't I
mean they could but I don't think they
will
all you do is you turn in receipts and
go here's what I spent I didn't spend
any more I didn't use this unwisely so
there you go being rational I would
trust Martha because she's my director
of sales and she's a person of character
and if they don't trust you that's a
whole other issue
perfect thanks guys you're so welcome
best of luck thanks for being awesome
hang on the line and we'll get you those
questions for humans conversation
starters for sure thanks for the call
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
if you've never experienced smart
conference before let me tell you the
energy in the room is absolutely
electric and that's before it even
starts there's something about being in
the arena with thousands of people who
you who care about the same things you
do get in control of your money
improving your mental health
strengthening your relationships and
building a successful career and hanging
out with George Campbell that's what
smart conference is so Chicago get ready
the Cubs have lost a lot we won't lose
smart conference is coming to you join
all of our Ramsay personalities Dave
Ramsey Rachel Cruz George Campbell Jade
warshaw Ken Coleman and myself me at
smart conference weekend on September
15th through 16th right now our early
bird general admission ticket price is
79 bucks and we have a limited VIP and
platinum tickets so don't wait to get
yours those always sell out super quick
the VIP
the VIP ticket I'm a great reader
everybody the VIP ticket includes a meet
and greet with Jade Rachel George Ken
and me and I love getting to meet you
all I hear your stories it's awesome so
seriously this is an action-packed
weekend it's a ton of fun non-stop
excitement go to ramsesolutions.com
events today to get your tickets
Ramsay's biggest event of the year go to
ramsaysolutions.com
events pump for this John I hope we
don't have a reading competition at this
event no I wouldn't do that to you I did
uh Mavis Beacon teaches typing you ever
do that I will out read and out type you
you did what and what and what never
mind John I thought you were cool and
hipping with it it was an old school
software where you could learn how to
type as a kid the people out there now
they know that's the most Millennial
thing you've said in a while besides man
I wish I could get my jeans tighter you
said that a minute ago but you said
um
an old school software yeah you know you
gotta for me old school is pre-software
like the old CD-ROM the old dad just
walk out on the on the front porch and
whistle and you have to come home
because he can't text you that's that's
the old days let's get to the phones
before they take us off the air Daniel's
up next in Austin Texas Daniel welcome
to the show
hey guys thanks for having me uh I had a
question in regards to uh I've been
listening to you guys the podcast with
Dave Ramsey's book Money Makeover
and we're I feel like we're almost there
and we are trying to decide if it's
going to be a smart decision or just
continue to make payments
on the final vehicle that I have
um one of my vehicles finally got paid
off about six months ago awesome if I
end up selling that
about 35
000 is what I'll get out of it and I can
try to put it towards the vehicle that I
announced which is the family car all
the kids are always on it the wife
drives it everywhere the current vehicle
that I have is only to take me to
working back
so I don't know if that's a smart
decision or just continue to pay what's
left on the loan
42 000.
okay and it's the only debt you have is
that one car loan
yes that's right what's the household
income
eighty two thousand
dude is that a 75 000 car
uh we got it for 58 it's a 2022
Highlander but you make 80 grand and you
have 77 000 worth of cars
yeah so we recently I'm active through
the military and we originally just PCS
uh moved to a new uh Duty station and
the current home that I had
at my old place I was able to sell it
and pay off all of my debt
um minus his vehicle that's just a lot
of car
comparatively
so I would sell it only because it was
too much car not just because you want
to pay off the loan yeah I'd sell it man
I hate to do that I'd rather see you in
a 2006 Camry that your buddies roll
their eyes when you pull in
um I'd rather see you in that until you
all can get a little more financially
secure
the other option is selling the family
car
yeah what's the family car
I'm talking about selling the Highlander
that's that's a note
yeah so that's the Highlander that's the
family car and the other one is a 2016
GMC Sierra
um I look in the market it runs uh
between 32 to 35 a private sale I could
probably get it for 36. and what about
the Highlander one of what could that
sell for
that I have not looked up
how much money do you guys have in the
bank
uh we have approximately seven thousand
tell me the specs on that Highlander
uh
fully loaded I mean it has everything
what year is it um 2022 how many miles
on it
I think it only has 17. we got it brand
new John will buy it well I I I was real
I've been in the market for a Highlander
for a while
um and so yeah you can get upwards of 40
for that without a problem 38 to 40. and
if you if you do it private Market you
can probably get as much as 42 43.
so the question is do you have two
options I see you could sell your paid
off car which doesn't free up a payment
but it does almost get rid of the debt
with your seven thousand you'll get
there right
yes or you could sell the Highlander and
get a cheaper family car
that's not forty two thousand dollars
okay or the Supreme the super complex is
I'd sell them both
I'd sell them both and I'd probably buy
a used Highlander back down about six or
seven years and you're still going to
pay a lot of money you can pay 25 grand
for it
um but you're gonna have cash and you're
gonna lose that precious Sierra and dude
I have a truck I get it it's you'll
probably shed a tear as it leaves and
you can get yourself a used Camry and
drive that sucker around and it's going
to be the worst being a military dude in
Texas in a Camry I get it but man you're
gonna be able to build something for
your family you're gonna accelerate that
a lot faster I like to plan of selling
both and keeping the cars under 40K
total and then having a fully funded
emergency fund it's a great spot to be
in thanks for the question all right our
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
take your home's efficiency and style to
the next level with their convenience
solutions from shelf Genie window Genie
and glass doctor visit neighborly.com to
schedule home service professionals near
you all right today's question comes
from Samantha in Virginia my husband and
I are planning to start paying off our
own student loans I owe about 30k I'm
currently and make 40K and when my
husband gets out of school next summer
he will owe around 150k and make a
hundred thousand my mother is guilting
me into paying off the parent Plus Loans
totaling about a hundred thousand that
she took out to help pay for my
education she claims that before I went
off to college I agreed to pay off any
loans she took out but I don't remember
this conversation and I feel like she's
making it up on top of this she has no
job and claims she can't afford the loan
how should we go about this poof this is
more relationship question than
financial question yeah
so legally
you have no obligation your mom took out
a loan in her name
and
I you're the one writing in so I trust
you y'all never had this conversation
she was so excited about her baby girl
going to college and she signed away all
this money and all of a sudden the bills
are coming in she's got no job no way to
pay it back and now you married some
fancy guy who's gonna make six figures
and she thinks you're gonna be rich and
she thinks you can just take all this on
so you have absolutely no legal
um responsibility on this debt and if I
were you I would just pay it
not not because Mom said
listen I I get it she she's changed the
deal on you she whatever it's it's my
college I'm gonna pay it Emma move on
it's gonna take me forever and I'm gonna
pay you last
we're gonna pay off the debt that I've
got sitting in my name and we're gonna
pay off my husband's debt and then we
will Circle back to this sucker but I
would also
um not give her a penny
not a penny all of this would go
directly to the Loan Servicing Company
if we get there
I I don't know that's that's how I'd
handle it man it may just be me taking
the high road and I would get all the
details on this because it's either
Napalm the relationship with Mom and
don't pay well mom is already napalmed
it yeah it's over anyways a lot of guilt
but looking at the numbers here you'll
have a 180 000 student loans plus 100
Parent PLUS making 140. it's gonna take
a while even throwing 60 70 80k at this
it's gonna take three four five years to
get rid of this but knowing that going
into it is going to help you guys
stomach this and going all right we got
a huge pile to clean up but we're gonna
have a great income to do that with and
we'll see what happens with the
relationship with Mom no guarantees
there thanks for the question this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney today if you enjoyed this show
you might enjoy some of the other shows
on the Ramsey network if you didn't know
Dr John's got his own show that he does
next door called the Dr John deloney
show and I've got a brand new YouTube
channel that's out there if you just
search for George camel on YouTube and
people are enjoying your show John and
they're enjoying yours well the comment
section on YouTube is brutal have you
ever been over there nope it's a party
man I do not go there when I first
started my YouTube show somebody wrote
some awful awful thing and they made
some of ins like wildly insane
clinical
response and I had worked in higher ed
for so long that I'm used to calling
back parents and dealing with some of
these and so I was trying to figure out
how to log in so I could give them my
cell number oh no that's how out of the
loop I was did I let John on the
internet I asked Abigail I was like hey
uh how do I log into this I need to give
this guy my number he's really not
jiving with my show and he's got some
incorrect information and she looked at
me and was like never never put yourself
smart anyway I just kind of avoid the
YouTube comments and here you are today
somehow surviving social media somehow
all right let's go to the phones Tessa
joins us all the way in Saskatchewan
Canada wow Tess are you with us
I am thank you for having me glad you
could join us across the border
thank you
what's going on
so my question is I'm We are following
the plan we've actually paid off almost
all our debt the only thing we have left
is
um our van payment should be done by the
end of the year way to go way to go
thank you thank you I guess I'm just
feeling a little not discouraged isn't
the word but is living paycheck to
paycheck the only way to walk the baby
steps everyone says living paycheck to
paycheck like it's a bad thing but I
feel like in order to follow the baby
steps that is the only way to live and
even once we're on to baby step number
three four five six seven we still will
be living paycheck to paycheck um I
guess it's just how do you get past that
stigma because is that not what we are
supposed to be doing that is a budget is
that is that not right I think we have
to Define living paycheck to paycheck
because the point of our plan is to stop
living paycheck to paycheck and so the
way I see that is you when you cover all
of just your bills you have no no money
left at the end of the month
okay and
yeah a zero-based budget where we say
your income minus expenses equals zero
that just means every dollar has been
allocated it doesn't mean that you have
zero margin it just means the margin you
have 400 bucks going towards your saving
goals now instead of just floating away
because you didn't make it or you have
300 going towards buying clothes and
getting a massage like living your life
right it's just being intentional
yes okay no and that makes sense I just
I always feel like people talk living
paycheck to paycheck and saying it like
it's a bad thing and I just keep
relating that to the baby steps I'm
thinking but is that not what we're
going to be doing forever but I see it
it's just allocating our money
differently and knowing where it's going
it means having a plan for your paycheck
which to me is the opposite and so I
yeah we're talking about the same thing
in different ways but no we we don't
advocate for living paycheck to paycheck
at all no in fact that makes sense we
all of us up here like Dave me Jordan we
have lived paycheck to paycheck before
and we know how scary that is I've had
to call a friend and ask to borrow a
credit card to go to the ER because I
was sick and I was married at the time
right I've walked around my house when
my wife was asleep and she didn't know
how bad it was like like we get it or
I'm gonna lose my house hey man can I
come live in your like we've I've been
there right so this whole thing is
giving people a path out of it what
you're experiencing right now as you're
on the back end of this you're almost
done with the running for your life part
and then you get to build
um a little bit of a safety net which is
your emergency fund right
yeah what you're finding what your eyes
are starting to open is just how sick
the culture is
it's Insanity right right exactly and
you're starting to see it because you're
experiencing you're slowly getting there
and you're realizing oh my gosh
everybody's living insane right you are
correct you're correct okay
that's where I was coming from it you
see
you see quick trips somewhere for the
weekend and you think how how could they
do that but that's why they're probably
in the mess that they're not real it's
not real yeah they're not doing okay
regardless of what their Instagram says
that's right thank you guys so so much I
appreciate it in the word keep spreading
the word across the border we appreciate
you all right let's go to Norfolk
Virginia where Chris is Chris welcome to
the show
hey how's it going great how are you
doing pretty good doing pretty good
what's going on
um so right now I'm kind of uh at a
a fork in my career right now
um I got a job offer
um
doing something that I'm not really
passionate about uh we're in the process
of uh going through the baby steps one
baby step two
um and I'm working multiple jobs right
now
um but
I'm not sure if I should just
if I do take this better paying job
um I'll have to quit all the other ones
but it's something that I don't see it
being long-term like by any means what
is the job
um so I'd be working
um basically it's an office job I'll be
a scheduler I'll be basically
um
dealing with like airplanes and whatnot
so yeah now they think you're qualified
for this did you apply for this job
or do they see you out
okay dude so why did you apply for it
um because I actually lost my job
um and I applied for two jobs at the
same time and it took a really long time
for me to get
word back from the better paying job
that is offering me the job right now
um it's not set in stone
um but 60 between 47 and 61 000. and
what are you making now
um roughly 33 there's other things that
I'm doing
um I
and these are just side jobs you're
doing a bunch of random gigs yeah
basically yeah how much debt do you have
um 26 000
I would take the job I'm taking it no no
because you're not passionate about all
these side hustles either are you
um actually the job that I'm in that's
eventually what I want to go to school
for what is it um uh I want to train
dogs okay cool can you do that on the
side
um I can but not you're doing it right
now on the side
oh that's such a great George Byrne
George Burn I'm just I'm just literally
asking I I think the money that I'm
making right now I could be making a lot
more if I had my certification you know
what I mean just go to somebody's house
and train somebody's dog so why don't we
take this new job get certification once
we're out of debt so let's focus on take
the new job get the income up let's get
out of that really fast so that we can
get the certification so we can get back
to dog training really fast that's the
shortest path I see
okay and look like like you're about to
double your income you're gonna double
your income yeah and let's let's justify
your concern a little bit if you were
had a job you just stumbled into or had
a friend who knew a guy or your dad knew
somebody and got you a job at an
Architecture Firm and they were actually
letting you be in the room when they
were doing r d and when they were doing
bidding and when they were talking with
clients and you wanted to go be an
architect
I might tell you hey man you want to sit
in on this one because you've got a
you've got a golden ticket that most
people will never get you'll have an
inside seat to this and it's going to
really enhance your schooling
you want to train dogs so if you step
away from that anybody is going to take
you to go get certification because
you're just gonna there's not like this
deep dark application process you're
gonna pay them you're gonna go train
dogs and then you're gonna hit the
market and nobody's gonna care they're
not gonna look at your resume and be
like what's explain the Gap when you
went to be an office manager for a few
years doubling your income No One's
Gonna ask you that question you're just
gonna be a great dog trainer man so I I
would take the job no questions asked
get your debt paid off and then start
planning your life after that you know
what to do man and we're going to send
you Ken Coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose to help you take another step
towards this dog training career that
you badly want and I think it's going to
show you the path to get there so hang
on the line we'll get you that resource
appreciate the call
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
James 4 14. why you do not even know
what will happen tomorrow what is your
life you are a Mist that appears for a
little while and then vanishes very emo
I love it in a turn of events Jack Black
once said I'm fairly certain that YOLO
is just carpe diem for stupid people
hey go back to that go back to that
scripture of the day why you do not even
know what will happen tomorrow what is
your life you are a Mist that appears
for a little while and then vanishes I
promise that's from My Chemical Romance
I think they use that I am fairly
certain that's a lyric
so emo we love to see it from James wow
maybe it's a real big fish yeah James
just sitting in the Poetry
good stuff I'm sitting in the corner
writing poetry about his dad
cool man well let's brighten things up
with our next caller it's Jessica from
Raleigh North Carolina Jessica welcome
to the show
what's going on
yeah so my husband and I are currently
doing steps four five and six we just
kind of made it there in the past couple
of months congratulations can we can we
cheer for you for a second way to go
sure that's awesome how much you pay off
me
I was about 24 okay congrats way to go
that's awesome
thanks so my question is I just also
started a new job in March and we have a
90-day waiting period before I can
contribute to my 401k and so I'm just
kind of wondering in that waiting period
if it makes sense to just kind of work
on five and six until I can start for my
husband's able to contribute to his so
right now he's I think contributing
about four or five percent
um but I'm just kind of trying to figure
out what to do with the Surplus in our
budget could you contribute to an IRA
I could I just I was waiting to figure
out like more about what the Max and if
there's a Ross 401k before I can treat
like before I put things in a different
investment opportunity
well I think right now your best
opportunity is the one in front of you
which would be probably a Roth IRA if
you guys are underneath the income
limits
or actually
okay so you could do a backdoor Roth as
well
okay so that's an option for you where
you fund the traditional with after tax
money and then convert it over and so
that would be a good option for you
again 90 days is not going to make or
break your retirement and so if you
wanted to throw it into the college fund
for those few months and front load that
that's fine or throw a little extra on
the home uh there's no like we're not
legalistic around here going well you
did it the wrong way Jessica you guys
are doing great
and so if I were you and you wanted to
follow the baby steps I would allocate
that money towards whatever investment I
could and right now that would be an IRA
that's great thank you thank you yeah
congratulations and once you get that uh
Roth 401k you can do all 15 there if
there's good mutual fund options and low
fees that's an easy way to knock out
your 15 what's a low fee well there's
there's but but comparatively to a Roth
IRA there can be different fees
depending on what fund you're investing
in you know it's it's generally like a
.06 percent okay you know that are not
huge or point two percent but depending
on what 401K you have in the ira you
have you you know it's it might be a
wash in the end okay
all right let's move on to Brian in
Tampa Brian welcome to the show
hey gentlemen thank you so much for
taking my call um I know you're up
against this I'll try to be brief what's
going on camera we got uh yeah so my
fiance and I was engaged back in October
and we found uh Ramsey uh a few weeks
ago so we've been diving in through
through the content and trying to watch
all the YouTube content
um we currently have a hundred and
eighty thousand dollars of debt the
majority of that being student loans but
we also have two cars
um her car is 23 300 out of six percent
interest uh remaining balance and my car
is twelve thousand five hundred uh
remaining balance
our combined income before taxes is
about a hundred thirty five thousand my
question is is if we should keep the
cars
um and then the second question is at
what point during the baby steps should
we start saving up for a wedding
okay so when is the wedding
we haven't set a date yet um
I think we still just kind of want to
work through like that first whoa so you
want to wait until all the debt is paid
off to get married
uh possibly yeah
that feels like it's going to take a
while you're gonna be engaged for five
years
so where we're living right now are rent
is relatively low it's about a thousand
dollars a month so I I think our shovels
are big enough to to work all right you
guys are already living together
yes okay that's that explains some of it
how much do you make
uh together we make about 135 before
taxes okay can I how honest can I be
with you medium or full
fall you promise
promise because I already know y'all
were just plugging along doing life and
then you ran into these videos and
already the size and scope of your the
next few years has already been altered
just because she ran into our crazy gang
on YouTube right
yeah definitely but at the same time
we're also energize that's awesome so
I'm gonna make it a little bit worse
okay
the last 20 years of my life the last 23
now
my life has been spent sitting with
people
when things have happened that they did
not see coming or they absolutely did
not expect
a not a majority but a huge chunk of
those
are The Blind Side when a fiance just
bails
when a husband calls and says I'm moving
out when a wife says I found somebody
else
and for you where you're sitting you are
Ironclad in your love it's never going
to happen to us and what I want to tell
you is my whole career has been based on
yeah but sometimes it does
and I tell you that not to freak you out
or to make you question that your fiance
but to tell you if you spend the next
three years you paying off her debt or
her paying off your debt
and then all of a sudden something
happens
and let's say you all go in and pay off
her student loans they're the smallest
ones smallest to largest you pay off for
student loans and then she leaves
or you leave
you have just put all that money in and
you have nothing to show for it
there's no recourse there's no nothing
that's why we're pretty adamant when you
get married to somebody there is a legal
process for separating that marriage
there is not that same process when
you're dating
so what I would tell you is man and this
is just gonna love you I would tell you
I would not pay off my partner's debt
until we are bound both spiritually and
legally
that's why I would tell you I'd go down
to the justice of the peace and get
married that's what I would do or we'd
have a small wedding with some friends
and we would throw rice at each other
and then call it good and plan a big fun
dramatic celebration once we've paid off
this 180 Grand that's what I would do if
I if you ask me like hey what would you
actually do in your real life that's
what I would do in my real life
or I would commit hey we we're going to
go in parallel we're both going to watch
FPU we're gonna do the baby steps but
I'm paying off my debt and you're paying
off your debt because it's not our debt
yet until we're legally bound up
okay and let's say that we do go down to
the courthouse and um kind of do that
legally
um at that point what would you think
about the cars
I I don't think the cars are the big
issues they're so small you can pay them
off and just keep them okay but the cars
aren't what's holding you guys back it's
those massive student loans and like
John was saying don't combine incomes
don't combine debt there's a lot of weak
conversation and I know you guys are
living together already but legally and
financially you need to keep everything
separate until you're married and the
moment you get married you put
everything in a in a pot there's not hey
you pay the light bill and I'll pay this
bill no we pay these bills because our
money is combined in this together and
that forces you guys to have
conversations about who we are gonna be
as a married couple and the vision we
have for the life we are building
together for ourselves our future our
Legacy our communities our country all
that stuff right we're gonna do that
stuff together but for now we're doing
separate debt snowballs we're using your
income to pay your debt choosing her
income to pay her debt smallest to
largest and then we'll see what happens
come wedding day and if you want a cash
flow a real small little thing that's
fine but I would not go spending 50
Grand on a wedding in the next few years
yeah I I I get that that student loans
knocked out I'd work a second job a
third job get the crap out of your life
man your whole life is being held up
right now by those student loans and
you've got so much joy and excitement on
the other end man I'll give you some
silver lining uh as a newlywed gift
we're going to give to you FPU Financial
Peace University go through it with your
fiance as kind of a pre-marital
counseling on the money side and I hope
that gives you guys some shared vision
and excitement for the future that puts
this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to all the folks in the
booth keeping the show afloat you
America until next time spend wisely
save intentionally and give generously
okay
it's Dr John deloney if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]